Nhưng vì tạo thống Mỹ khẳng đình vẫn giữ lập trường cường dành với người đồng cấp về nizzier là
Ông đi của la sma đúng không bị đoạn tình tình gạo buộc cầm đầu bằng đảng cát theo để lo sâu lẽ s, đuôn lộu mà tuy vào miếng
Bunga giáo miếng cũng trở bị đưa tổ chức này vào dành xách khủng bố nước ngoài
Mời đường xác các biển pháp trường pháp và tấn công tài xam
Hồi tổ chức, nhà trắng đã học bà lên để bàn phương and quân sự
Mà ngồn khả năng tập kích trên bộ của bà về nizzier là
Lâu năm góc xác nhận hiện nỏng tác trên tổ xam bài USS,
Trời ra a phó đã ở ngoài khôi về nizzier là cùng tạm tổ chến một tổ ngầm hạt nhân
Và nhiều tiêm kích em bà me lòng như đại nhất
Cung ngày 15,000 mồn của tôi mũ của tổng thống đúng năng trông
Mồ chình sẽ nghĩ thông bà ở bà người đã bị tự dạ trông của tần công thứ 20,000 mồn
Nhằm bà tổ tình gì trở mà tuy kể để đoạn tránh chiến
Năng tổng xuống người thì mạc lên hơn tà mười
Các tổ chức nhân quyền nhiều nghĩ sĩ và thăm chỉ là cảm một số đồng mình của Washington
Đã đã đặt đi vận tổ chức khách pháp của chình rình
Lâu ngày đây là hành động sét người ngoài phòng pháp lần trong cuộc biển của tế